[Music]
next js create fast search engine
optimize react apps with zero
configuration
a traditional react app is rendered
client side where the browser starts
with a shell of an html page
lacking any rendered content from there
the browser fetches the javascript file
containing the react code to render
content to the page
and make it interactive but there are
two major drawbacks with client-side
rendering
one the content is not reliably indexed
by all search engines
or read by social media link bots and
two it can take longer to reach the
first contentful paint when a user first
lands on the web page
next is a framework that allows you to
build a react app but render the content
in advance on the server
so the first thing a user or search bot
sees is the fully rendered html
after receiving this initial page
client-side rendering takes over
and it works just like a traditional
react app it's the best of both worlds
fully rendered content for bots highly
interactive content for users
inside of a next project you have a
pages directory each javascript file
defined here
exports a react component that
represents a route in the application
in other words the file structure here
mirrors the actual urls that the user
will navigate to
and next provides its own router to make
navigation seamless
but the real magic comes into play when
we talk about data fetching
because next can perform multiple server
rendering strategies from a single
project
static generation or pre-rendering
allows you to render your pages
at build time each page or component can
implement a function called
get static props it might fetch data
from a cloud database then pass the data
as props to the component
you can then build your app to render
out all the html locally
and upload it to a storage bucket where
it can be easily cached by a cdn
that works great for a blog or any kind
of app where the data doesn't change
often
but if the data does change often you
can implement server side rendering
which builds the html page
each time it's requested by the user in
the component we implement data fetching
with the get server side props function
instead of running at build time this
function runs at request time
that means the page will fetch the
latest data on the server each time a
new request comes in
that's great for pages with rapidly
changing data but maybe you want
something in between yet another option
is incremental static regeneration by
simply adding a revalidate option to get
static props
next can regenerate a page whenever a
new request comes in
within a certain time interval this has
been next js in 100 seconds
if you want to see more short videos
like this make sure to subscribe and hit
the like button
then open up the s code and get ready to
go beyond 100 seconds with a full
breakdown of next
before we get going i'd like to point
out that i'm working on a full react
next firebase course which i hope to
have finally finished by the end of
january
which will be available to fireship pro
members my goal over the next few
minutes
is to teach you the fundamentals of next
while also explaining the complexities
of server-side rendering
to follow along open up the terminal and
run npx
create next app followed by the name of
your app and if you get lost at any
point
make sure to grab the source code on
github or fireship io
let's open up the project in vs code and
then go into the package.json file
in development the only script we need
to worry about is dev
which you can execute by running npm run
dev
from the command line which will run our
app on localhost 3000
that should give you the default
boilerplate in the browser now before we
get into the react code
there's a few things that i want to
point out first in the styles directory
here you'll notice how next supports css
modules
in the globals file you can define
styles that apply to the entire
application
but in other files with dot module you
can define classes that only apply to a
specific route or component
and you don't have to worry about coming
up with a bunch of unique class names or
naming conventions when managing your
styles
if you want to use styles from a certain
module you just import the style sheet
in your javascript
then reference your styles in jsx as if
the styles were a javascript object
that's pretty awesome but from there
let's shift our attention over to the
pages directory
inside this directory we define all the
pages and routes for the application
at the highest level we have this
underscore app.js file which is like the
main entry point into the app
in other words every individual page
will start from this template
currently the application only has one
page which points to the root url
and is defined by the component in the
index.js file
when a user navigates to this url next
will find the default export which is a
react component
in this file so every file or page in
your application
needs to have one default export to
demonstrate this further
let's create our first route in the
pages directory create a new file called
hello.js
then we can define the content of this
page by exporting a default react
component from it
from there we can go back to the browser
and navigate to localhost 3000
slash hello and we should get the
content of that component
congratulations you just built your
first web page with next
but now let's imagine a route that's a
little more complex we have a cars route
that should show a list of cars
then an infinite number of cars that
might be dynamically generated
under that url we can implement a
dynamic route like that
by first creating a cars directory then
inside the directory we'll add an
index.js file
which will show the main list of cars
then for each individual car
we'll add a component that has a file
name of brackets
paramname dot js the brackets make this
route dynamic
which means anytime a user navigates to
cars
slash whatever or cars slash tesla
it will render the component in this
file to see that in action
let's go ahead and implement the
component logic in the index file we'll
just add a placeholder for the car's
list for now
but in the dynamic component we'll
import the use router hook from the next
router
it allows us to access the query
parameters from the url
in this example the value is id but you
can give it a name of whatever you want
and then we'll render that value out to
the template now back in the browser
if we go to the car's url it renders out
the car's component
then if we add any string after the
car's url it renders out the dynamic
component
now one other thing you may have noticed
in the pages directory is this api
directory
so what is that all about the api
directory is a special part of next
for setting up routes that will only
apply to the server
that can be useful because the code you
write here won't increase the
client-side javascript bundle that needs
to ultimately be sent over the network
we're not going to get into api routes
in this video but just know that it's a
useful feature when you have work that
needs to be done on the back end
or if you simply want to expose an api
for your end users
but now let's shift our attention over
to the most valuable feature in next
which of course is data fetching next
allows us to fetch data
and render html on the server and again
the benefit of doing that
is that the end user gets rendered
content quicker and the content can be
reliably crawled by search bots and
social media link bots
now when it comes to server rendering
there are two main options
static generation and server side
rendering
static generation is also called
pre-rendering because you generate all
the html
at build time it makes life very simple
because you generate a bunch of html
files
then upload them to a storage bucket or
static host
and they can be delivered with very high
performance over a cdn
but there's a couple of big trade-offs
here the first one is that your data may
become stale
if the data on the server changes you
need to rebuild and redeploy your site
in order for those changes to be
reflected
another important trait i have to think
about is scale if your website has a
million pages it'll be very slow and
difficult to pre-render all of them
that makes static generation most
well-suited for data that doesn't change
often
and for sites that have a relatively low
number of total pages
a good example would be a blog because
it might have a few hundred pages and
those pages likely don't change on a
daily basis
let's go ahead and take a look at how we
might implement static generation in
next
in the car component let's imagine we
need to fetch data from an external
source
like a database or api to simulate that
for the demo i've added a couple of json
files to the public directory
we have a file that returns an array of
ids then an individual response
for each car which contains an image and
other data about the car
now we can fetch this data for the car
component by implementing
the get static props function inside the
component file
when you build your site next will
automatically call this function
then send the result as props to the
component itself
what we want to do here is fetch the
json for an individual car
so it can be used in the html or ui for
the cart page
in this case we need the id from the url
to know which car was requested
we can get that information from the
params argument and the function
then from there we'll use the fetch api
to make a request to localhost
to request the json file with that id
we can then convert it to json then the
final step is to return an object
that has a props property where each
prop can then be accessed by the
component
up in the component code we can
destructure the car prop and then use it
in the jsx
which i'm doing here by adding an image
tag which relies on the data fetched by
the server as the image source
now if you're concerned about search
engine optimization you likely want to
add an
seo friendly title as well as meta tags
to the head of the document
next makes that very easy to accomplish
by simply importing the head component
anything inside this component will be
rendered out to the head of the document
like in this case we add a title with
the car color and id
and we could also add meta tags for
twitter and facebook cards if we wanted
to
now because we're working with a dynamic
route there's one other thing we have to
keep in mind
and that's the fact that next has no way
of knowing how many pages we actually
have associated
to a dynamic route in order to
pre-render all the car ids
next needs to know those ids in advance
and the way we provide that information
is by implementing the get static paths
function
this function can also request data from
an api
or database then its job is to return a
paths object
that contains an array with every route
for this dynamic url
in this demo we only have three routes
tesla forward and lambo
we map those values to an array of
objects then return them from the
function
along with additional options like the
fallback behavior
now if we go visit the app in the
browser we should see a fully rendered
web page
it doesn't look any different than a
regular react app however
if you open up the sources panel in
chrome dev tools it'll show you the
fully rendered html
before it was touched by javascript
notice how it contains the title
and pre-rendered content which is
essential for seo
and sharing content on social media
sites so that's how you implement server
side generation
but another big strategy is server side
rendering
the big difference is that with ssr the
content is generated on a server
when requested by the user this approach
is ideal when data changes constantly
because it ensures the end user will
always get the latest and greatest data
from whatever your data source happens
to be
however it's far less efficient because
you need to have a server in place to
respond to those requests
as opposed to caching everything on a
global cdn
imagine something like an ebay auction
where you have millions of listings
and those listings are changing all the
time that's probably a good candidate
for
ssr in any case it's very easy to
implement it next
back in our page file we'll go ahead and
implement another function
called get server side props the only
thing that actually changes in our code
is the name of the function
we can simply copy the body of the git
static props function
and paste it into our new function it
does the exact same thing
but does it on every request instead of
it build time
then we can comment out get static props
and get static paths because we no
longer need those functions
but the real beauty of next is that we
can apply both of these paradigms
wherever we want in the application
we're not limited to one or the other
i'm going to go ahead and wrap things up
there if there's anything you want to
see in my full next course
make sure to let me know in the comments
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one